I'm going red line aim is purified and
welcome to you the Testament um
this game has been suggested to me so
many times I literally don't know
anything about it except that Jesus is
involved new incarnation if you are
religious a strong believer and like
sense of humor about it uh I don't
[ __ ] know random character Baba
totally look like a Baba now let's just
go with beauty
Baha mo our home time is let's go in
Bethlehem where a guy we're [ __ ] how
can you be 70 let's go in it I talk
anything [ __ ] talk on the edge are
you kidding me why should I be this big
and make no sense alright let's make it
a little younger
[ __ ] forty all right chubby why can I
change this okay angry I can't even see
his face this does not help it maximum
strength save and exit
what's going on the change to maximum
resolution I don't know why
ah so sexy look at his [ __ ] face what
it what is Kevin what I did a karate
kick uh I'm just setting and meditating
I have no idea what's the point of iziz
why am I going farther away what is this
what are you coming from
hey fellow guardian you may think I'm
huge you're absolutely right
what is he saying what okay that is good
oh I can check and [ __ ] why is the mouse
keep moving all right hey don't dissolve
that fellow man he is part of our
society people of Israel listen to what
I have to say what are they doing having
a gangbang listen to I repent for the
kingdom of God or something the water i
baptize you with it's symbolic there is
one among you who will demonstrate this
job prepare attack what the [ __ ]
what is him as I sighs for tall he will
strike in the way and yell out there did
you have God to judge oh you're [ __ ]
best food but good guy what if you do it
it's they must follow now you must take
race so that you must so that he may
increase all right I guess but who is
this same year on which you space I
trick you talk like all the others I've
already speak it's just a [ __ ] bag
yeah yeah riddles because you had a mind
this week those who listen have heard of
all that is they need this is [ __ ]
bet ten out of ten so far holy [ __ ] open
your mind and trust your instincts few
will ever have the opportunity that lies
before ya
okay can we skip this stupid engine up
up that was an awkward moment filming my
crotch hi stop fighting stop fighting
boom Shaka hey Betty I saw you steal
that stack put it down in it in there
that will be trauma who is talking to me
the nipple yes no it's my [ __ ] well it
better be worth it because I'm gonna
beat you up until you give it up well
it's gonna be but what is he shut it
what's with the angles [ __ ] you it's my
staff
it's my stack you can't tell me
otherwise slap that what am I do it what
am i doing what am i doing I'm out of
here this is so stupid
look at uh what are they looking at some
mouths and everything I why is this a
game what is ow ow oh no get up pills
you're not done yet you're not
what do you stop rubbing this get up
come on what is this you're not Luke
[ __ ] you don't have boards so anyway -
what whether die there alright sorry I'm
back that spider-man over there
and they go over to him what do you want
what is this move what is this doing to
him I want to sit this looks so wrong
are we hugging is he hugging him what
out I guess huh oh no I didn't wanna die
god damnit son of [ __ ] I just let's
keep going with this
I feel like this game anything can
[ __ ] happen okay let's go over to
spider-man you know I'm a lava okay you
run with them I gotta remember that [ __ ]
and you pick up and eat sand with X
thank you for that seriously though you
[ __ ] eat sand you don't have any
other groceries on your list
well jet we need to figure out least
vitamin C sub spider-man hey spider-man
how can you sit there like a filthy
beggar when the Messiah himself walks
amongst yep that's my eyes like yeah if
you're looking for God you would do
better to look within yourself that's
where it dwells good point spider-man
you're more likely to find a prophet in
the quiet of the desert than the plaster
good point again spider-man wait
spider-man isn't black why would a king
slum in the wilderness the only thing
that rains there is death
his face is seriously disturbing his
face is exactly the slash dies but the
spirit lips therefore that I what
survives is not of this world and for
the desert and see what you can find you
may discover that your closes guard and
you think all right we are on a godly
journey oh and there's a sign right
[ __ ] there that's a desert let me
just hump the air my way forward here
let's go to the desert [ __ ] love this
game and so do things you can know I was
thinking about look what am I do it okay
we find spider-man again let me run over
to him hey spider-man you again you
think how the hell did is teleport you
didn't camping out here in the desert
makes you savior that would work for you
really the Messiah turn this doesn't
bread and give us something inked and I
kind of live by bread alone all day by
the end of it I makes the bread good
point spider-man why are you closing
feel so close to God then why bother
medicating meditating [ __ ] it
snap out of it and talk to me like a
normal person it's the one who talk like
that don't push your luck if you take
your father from granted then you'll
make it home but why bother what but why
whoever made I can sorry I'm jumping
what it going to do I promise you today
you have waited for is that hat please
leave me now you just [ __ ] told him
to follow him [ __ ] you man like you
spider-man
alright I mean just the angle here that
was it this is all you find in the
desert are you kidding me let's go to
God ara
let me just walk my normal walk this is
totally how normal people walk it's got
a load between there's a lot of files to
load in a lot of data so you know it's
understandable bag playing now [ __ ]
best game ever seriously 11 out freaking
thousand out of 1000 freaking thousand
out 100 hey man how you doing
sorry I didn't mean to kick you I'm a
giant the big pie the giant Messiah
I'm here to salivate you don't block oh
[ __ ] 6/7 sad me okay well you know
what I'm gonna ride you like a pony
what did I what is this what am I saying
here why is he changing ACK
huh what am i doing okay
I'm sorry sir I'll just keep good decide
man have a banana he has a banana give
me that get out of my way you guard
I want that banana hey hey stop where
you are buddy what are you doing excuse
me what are you doing at with this
everyone is looking up at this hour you
got no business snooping around at night
sit down I yes no leave me alone and
stop sucking on my nipple well I do get
bored on the graveyard shift
turn your pot will give me something to
do Oh we'll see about that
we'll see about how well I just want to
hug you what the [ __ ] is that Naruto
[ __ ] [ __ ] hey show some respect you
are under arrest for insurrection
we'll see what jury has to say about
this
oh no what will happen
i cat up weird teleported into somewhere
else Jimi Hendrix predict when the power
of love okay I see how the Roman Empire
looks after you people were plucked to
fall foul criminals from society as a
father
okay I can't stand this what would you
prefer pity who stands accused of
insurrection I don't [ __ ] know or
would you like to have the sky whoa he
looks high as [ __ ] nice parenting forget
that that's the father these crimes are
insignificant my kanya is my Issus but
for them truth can crucify me at least
Konya cares about his pee what is wrong
with his face
it looks highest [ __ ] the deciding vote
lies within me and I say pity we should
be Fred leave Canyon to rot in the well
other people I was [ __ ] at it scared
it spoken to people it's not the people
it's cat is is he's [ __ ] you should
be arrested for drugs holy [ __ ] high I
can't take this anymore
check okay Fred
I will definitely make a part two of
this like and favorite to be enjoyed
okay go read today and I'll see you next
video whatever makes Emperor that we're
back at Titanic Leo do something make
your movement is this well why not
Oh like pixel what are you doing